i want to run a marathon and i'm really
hoping to get blisters and to get ill
and to fail or whatever it's not like
that at all i don't think people court
suffering in that sort of way but at the
same time people know that if it didn't
have the possibility of failure and
difficulty and struggle it wouldn't be
seen as meaningful you don't want to
fail but on the other hand the chance of
failure has to be part and parcel of the
thing
holy welcome to the show
thanks for having me back my pleasure
man why are we talking about suffering
today
i have come up with a new book uh called
uh the sweet spot uh the pledge was
suffering a search for meaning and it is
a topic which i have been occupied by
for many years and i think it's
absolutely fascinating i think suffering
connects to all sorts of probably some
nice explanations for some very odd and
puzzling behavior
connects to movies connects to sex
connects to purpose and life and um and
it's just and i think also just tells us
some interesting things about human
nature what's the
you're meant you're the man to talk to
about this
yeah true what's the uh core message of
the book
um when i started the book i i was
interested in puzzles about um what what
psychologists called monae masochism so
why do people like spicy foods or hot
baths or scary movies or sad movies and
all of that
and i was just focusing on the role of
i'm explaining the message is going to
be here's why we use pain and suffering
to to increase the kind of pleasure in
our lives
but as i began to do this more and more
and look at this and read philosophers
and read psychologists
i began to realize a lot of the
suffering we choose isn't in the service
of
pleasure but in the service of other
goals like meaning and morality
so
pretty late into working on the book i
think the message is
um what you could call motivational
pluralism which is people want more than
one thing we want pleasure but we also
want morality we want meaning
and
that's one bitter message the rest of
the message is that sometimes chosen
suffering of the right sort is just what
we need to get us there
how do you define
pleasure
meaning and morality
it's a good question um
you could coordinate you could start off
by defining it in kind of a rough and
intuitive way so roughly pleasures
things we seek out we go make us smile
make us happy give us a glow you know so
if you're hungry a hot foot sunday's
pleasure for most of us uh you know
sex being loved
nice artwork
a beautiful walk and a beautiful day
that's pleasure
um
morality is doing the right thing
and you know doing the right thing which
could mean involve fairness and justice
it could mean helping somebody could
mean harming somebody
applying some sort of more moral rule or
principle
and meaning is a different animal
altogether connected to the other two
but but meaning is
um
[Music]
a pursuit connected to that has
significance
that
uh takes a while
that influences other people that
involves goals and sub goals
and
most of all requires
some degree of difficulty
sometimes physical pains nice anxiety
sometimes suffering
if you have a pursuit and you find it
easy
and natural and fun it probably isn't a
meaningful one
it could be a fun one so you know a fun
pursuit is eating some m ms going for a
nice walk a meaningful pursuit could be
raising children starting a business uh
going to war
a moral pursuit could be helping a
friend in trouble you know trying to
punish somebody who did something wrong
trying to to fight for justice
and they're all related but they take
you in different directions
what are some of the ways that people
use suffering to get pleasure then
yeah there's a lot of ways um
the simplest answer is probably simply
contrast
so
um
one of the tricks we can do
is we can experience a bit of chosen
pain
and so as to make the subsequent
experience more pleasurable
you know you eat really spicy food that
burns your mouth and you take a swig of
beer and that feels magnificent um
you you um
you go into really hot sauna hot hot say
a hot finish sauna you dive into a cool
lake and then you are in bliss
uh or or take a broader time scale you
see um you must have seen john wick
yeah you don't wait so beginning a movie
is they kill a stock no it's in a
trailer not not a spotter they kill his
dog that's actually very sad he loved
that dog he's a retired assassin and he
has a dog his dead wife gives him a dog
loves his dog they kill the dogs and but
when russian mobsters this bad thing
happens
but then
he goes and takes his revenge and kills
everybody in a comic explosion of
homicide um and
the second two thirds of the movie
is enjoyable because the first third
sets up the contrast
and it would be a mistake for you to say
oh john wick great movie you know would
have made it better if you took away the
dog part which was really a bummer
because it got to be so much fun because
you had the contrast in the beginning
and there are people who do these these
big data analyses of movies and stories
and and novels and plays and a very
typical pattern is
things get bad bad bad and then they get
better
and there's a pleasure to that
inherent in that you talk about the
importance of the ordering or the
sequence
of yes suffering and pleasure can you
dig into that
um
there's all these interesting facts
about ordering and time
that i think we know in our gut
intuitively and we often play with it
but here's the simplest
you have bad stuff you have good stuff
that's the order you wanted then so uh
i'm doing movies today so you know
shawshank redemption this guy spends 20
years in prison for a crime
presumably didn't commit although
there's there's weird interpretation of
the movie where it's unclear but um
and then and this is spoiler day but um
but he escapes and spends the rest of
his wonderful life in a in a mexican
beach
and that's a and you feel wonderful at
the film imagine that we're reversed
you know he's living on his mexican
beach having a wonderful time with his
with his friend uh and everything and he
ends up increasing the rest of his life
the same amount of time that would suck
and in general there's sort of a balance
we want things to get better there's
these studies which um ask people about
the kind of jobs they want so you want a
job that starts off low paying and gets
higher paying higher paying higher
paying or to reverse and imagine it so
happened that this is calibrated so that
maybe the one that went down gives you
more money in total still who wants that
you want things to get better
and so to sort of the dance of time and
sometimes we sometimes we do the dance
of time
to give ourselves pleasure in kind of
clever ways so one of my favorite
studies is by george lowenstein he asked
people this great question he says
imagine you could kiss your favorite
movie star and ellipse fully
consensually and pleasurable
and then he says
when do you want to do it
now
psychology 101 says right now
self-control is hard we're greedy for
time economics 101 says right now
because you you know you you you're the
same sort of temporal discounting better
get ten dollars today and ten dollars
tomorrow that's why we have interest and
so on people say two days
it was two days
and it turns out that what people want
to do is they want to savor the idea
they want to they want to take some time
to savor an anticipation
of of the pleasure they're going to get
similarly for bad things even though
economics and psychology says put them
off as long as you can and sometimes we
do that sometimes we try to get him over
with because we're worried about the
experience of dread what like
pardon me what like in what ways would
you do it oh i uh uh take a dentist
appointment
so under some circumstances you just put
it off put it off put it off put off
forever but sometimes things weigh on
you
and if you ask people you want to do it
now or you want to do it tomorrow it'll
say now hit me with it now let's get it
over with
and it's true there's a there'd be a
rationality to doing it tomorrow because
you know maybe you'll die or something
and then you're lucky you have to get
the appointment but um but if you if you
do it uh
now at least you don't have to live
through the the dread
i wrote a newsletter about this a little
while ago and termed it anxiety cost so
in the same ways you have opportunity
cost the anxiety cost of
it was a justification for me if someone
has a daily habit that they want to do
let's say it's meditation or it's some
stretching or it's
walk the dog or do whatever it is
i argued that because your
daily requirement resets essentially
every morning as soon as you wake up
that's the beginning of your day to
complete this if you spend most of the
day reminding yourself that you still
need to do that thing later on in the
day you've spent that day suffering this
anxiety cost whereas if you get your
morning routine locked in and you
meditate first thing you just get to
bathe in the fact that this
self-righteousness up on your high horse
for the rest of the day being so
congratulatory about the fact that you
meditated and did your stretching first
thing
i love giving advice and
it's the primary bit of advice which is
do your most important thing right away
in the morning
and
most important this is also the hardest
you know if it's easy and fun you could
you could wait a bit but and for me it's
writing which is you know i i'll i want
to write an hour each day and if i don't
do it in the morning i can put it off
and i feel bad and so on but you just
you just want to get it done right away
and you know there's a satisfaction in
it it's it's an example of something
there's all sorts of activities
um working out and writing are two real
go-to examples that aren't that much fun
when you when you do them
you know i don't know maybe your mileage
may vary but you know there's always you
know there's always email or twitter or
hanging out with friends and so on
but having done them gives you a certain
satisfaction
and that's another reason for the for
the contour that we want yeah so that's
contrast but you also talk about
signaling and mastery as well
yes there's um
there's all sorts of things so one of
the one one reason and then there's one
other which we'll mention but one way
you get uh pleasure from suffering is
the pleasure of a good name
jeremy bentham's term of good reputation
so sometimes we we choose to suffer to
impress others with how tough we are you
know um
yeah i
i i was once sat with my son and some of
his friends and they started having a
wasabi eating contest and you know they
wouldn't have done it by themselves but
all the guys are there and they wanted
to show how tough they are in a
religious context you may want to show
how pious you are
and there's all sorts of religious
rituals involving a lot of suffering and
pain and deprivation but you do them to
show you know look look look look what a
believer i am look how how faithful i am
to god um
sometimes
a very different thing is when people
will cut themselves or harm themselves
as a cry for help and there you're not
signaling strength you're signaling uh
need
so you have you have a
signaling
as one thing you have the joy of mastery
it feels good to be um
to be in control of something to be able
to sort of exert your will over your
body and this is
one important contrast i make in the
book which is absolutely critical is i'm
talking about chosen suffering unchosen
suffering bad stuff that happens is a
very different thing
so c.s lewis
gives a great example of fasting
where he says you know um if you're not
eating because you have no food you
can't afford any food or someone's
locked you in a room with no food that
just sucks that's just you just
suffer
try to make the most of it but that's
awful but if you're not eating because
you're fasting
then you could feel proud in fact c.s
lewis being c.s lewis disapproves and
says you know you shouldn't be so proud
of yourself just just you know worship
god and get over yourself but but still
there's a sense of pride
and and one other thing since we're
going through the list that pain can do
is it could be an escape from from
yourself
it can it can be escaped from
consciousness um
you know i described my book the first
time i ever sparred brazilian jiu jitsu
and rolled with somebody who you know
was like everybody else in the gym
younger and stronger than me and so it's
like two minutes three minutes
and i realized afterwards that during
that period i thought of nothing else
i didn't worry about my my the class i
have to teach or the embarrassing thing
i said to my partner or money problems
whatever i didn't think i wonder how i'm
looking and everything like that i was
totally immersed in this and
difficulty does that for you
you know pain does that for you of all
the bad things to be said about pain one
good thing is it certainly focuses the
attention
you told me a story the last time that
we spoke
about a dominatrix
who said was the quote nothing captures
attention like a whip
you have a good memory yes yes i don't
know why we're talking about say i
wasn't even studying sadomasochism but
such a good quote
um yes um
yes you know
he says something like you hold it up
and people's eyes cannot cannot move
away from it
and this is you know
there's i think a deep insight here
there's uh a wonderful theoretical paper
uh on art
asking the question why is so much art
through history grotesque
and unpleasant
and the answer is because art is in a
constant battle for eyeballs you know
you want people to notice your artwork
and um and something that's grotesque or
unpleasant
captures captures it
you know you you look at something like
i don't know um
uh something a grotesque scene of
cannibalism or
torture and it just captures you
and of course movies work in the same
principle
why do we like scary movies
i think there's different reasons but i
think that there's one general
answer to that which extends to why we
like scary things in general
which is
our mind is naturally drawn to worst
case scenarios
in some way be a lot of fun
you know you're free of nothing to do
you just you to think about good stuff
to imagine yourself winning a prize or
somebody falls in love with you and
everything
but those don't pose any puzzles if i
win a great prize i'll say thank you and
accept it and that's great but what's
useful and i think
this is one part of my book where i do
get sort of adaptationists i think where
there's a darwinian advantage
to thinking about the bad stuff to think
about what happens when the world goes
to hell
the thing about what happens when when
your life gets messed up in some way an
advantage to thinking about these things
is
that it um
that it basically gets you to prepare
and ruminate and deliberate and there's
some evidence that people who have
positive fantasies actually make out
less well in the world than people have
negative fantasies how'd you mean
thinking about bad stuff
well this is some stuff by uh by a
psychologist um
blank on her name at nyu so she tests
these people who are looking for
romantic relationships they're they're
you know they're single they'd like to
find a partner and she asked him how
often do you fantasize about being in
love how have you found us to be being
with the man or woman of your dreams
and the people who say a lot
tend to be the same people that six
months later don't have a partner
the people who are in another study she
asked people who want to lose weight
and he said do you ever think of
yourself being fit and strong and
everything yeah a lot of times and the
people again the people who think about
that a lot
tend to be the people who don't lose as
much weight and her theory of it is that
for these positive fantasies what you do
is you sort of
you you kind of consume the pleasure
in your imagination and you're less
motivated to do it in real life if i
really fantasize a lot about having a
girlfriend then maybe i try less hard to
have a girlfriend i got my fantasies
after all
now negative
ruminations don't have that problem they
are they are always focused on the worst
case and i think to go back to your
question one reason why we like scary
movies
is that um
they are
imaginary and imaginative depictions of
worst case scenarios so take you know
take zombie films zombie tv shows you
know you can make fun of the idea and
say you really need to prepare for a
zombie apocalypse but
these movies and tv shows are never
about zombies actually what they are is
what happens when the world goes down
and there's no government there's no
police the dangers in zombie movies are
almost always people not zombies
and so we're drawn to this
and then there's other ingredients so so
you might think fear is negative but
and in fact there were some early
theories that said that the people who
like horror movies aren't as afraid as
people as the people who hate them it's
going to be total nonsense people who
like horror movies are just as afraid as
people who don't like them but they
enjoy being afraid
and for any negative emotion in the
right context
particularly a context where it's
imaginary
so you know there's no real danger it
could be a source of pleasure you can
enjoy being afraid you enjoy being angry
even enjoy being sad
could you enjoy physical pain under the
right circumstances
well there's people who go out of their
way to watch sad movies the ones that
make them cry and make them their eyes
out at the end
it is interesting to think about the
fact that there's this it's almost like
a sandbox
a safe play pen in which we can indulge
ourselves in some of the emotions that
are at the extreme areas of life you
know i would wager that there'll be some
people that will go through life and
some of the most extreme emotions
perhaps that they feel in their entire
lives will be during
watching movies
yes
yes or that's right
um
or
related to this will involve events that
are so far away from them
to um to be effectively fictional when
princess diana
was killed uh died in his car crash
people mourned
to an extraordinary degree and there
were people who went on tv and said uh
you know this was the worst thing that's
ever happening when my mom died that was
sad but oh when princess diana died that
was that was really sad we we consume
these emotions
and i think
it it there's a safety to it
you know
the death of my child would be would
would destroy me
but the death of a child in a movie i
could vicariously feel sadness but the
same time i know
nothing bad has really happened
i could feel afraid but i know nothing
scary nothing dangerous is really
about about to to
to happen so you're safe
in some way people have described the
pleasures of imagination as a form of
safe play
i suppose
yeah i suppose that bdsm is kind of
similar to this but it's got it's acting
on a number of the different
pathways so you have the contrast effect
that you have something that is painful
and it continues and it continues and
then the relief is the moment at which
the pain no longer is pain and therefore
that's pleasure but you also have this
presence this escape from self perhaps
you have a
signaling aspect to whoever it is that
you're with look at how perhaps strong
or resilient i am you can't hurt me and
then maybe there's even a
essence of mastery in that
you are
put into a situation that you know your
physiology should be responding to with
panic um let's say it's
asphyxiation or let's say that it's
being hit the usual response should be
something other than the one that you
are giving which is arousal yes
in some way bdsm is a perfect storm
where all of the different theories of
the pleasures of pain kind of come in
and click
and
and that raises the question that i do
not have an answer to
which is why do some people like and
some people don't
um and same with some people i know like
to cry at movies some people not not not
even close some people like spicy foods
others don't and i'll be i'll be totally
honest because i i often think about
this um we have no theory
as to why
some people are this and some people are
not
you know it used to be thought that bdsm
is kind of pathological and you kind of
look for people with other disorders it
turns out not to be true you know people
who engage in that are no more likely to
suffer psychological problems or have in
some way bad personalities than people
who who don't
and at some level the appetite for it is
very popular
more often in the imagination and then
they're doing so you know as i was doing
research for the book i was looking up
uh 50 shades of gray just a bdsm story
and it was the most popular book of the
last decade
like this from 2010 to 2020 that's the
most popular book the second most
popular book was the sequel the third
most popular book was the end of the
trilogy so there's definitely an
audience for this sort of stuff though i
imagine that the vast majority of these
people wouldn't engage in anything
serious
you looked at the sexual fantasies and
how they differ between men and women i
think that was seth stephens
davidowitz's work and yeah he's
a past guest on the show that guy is an
animal of a data scientist what did you
what did you find out from his work
weird stuff um yeah yes it's
weird stuff um
there's there's from his book there's
another book called something like 10
billion wicked thoughts
and
basically if you you know sex research
into what people like the uses to ask
people
and you know
it's very difficult people be honest
they're often embarrassed or sometimes
confused
but
maybe one of the purest um
manifestations of what people like is
what they look at when looking at
pornography
and so what uh
so what this data analyst did was he got
hold of pornhub data of which there was
a lot of in fact pornhub data not only
um looks at the search terms
but um
but it also does google analytics to
make a very good guess as to whether
you're a man or woman how old you are
whether you're gay or straight or bi or
whatever and and there's all sorts of
surprises um
but the biggest surprise to me which i
don't have such a good story about is
that
contrary to everything while anything i
would have expected um he finds that
women tend to search out violent sex or
humiliating sex far more frequently than
men do
and this is weird because
men are just on the whole far more
violent with more violent taste and
entertainment in general um
a lot of these depictions involved in
victimization of women
and you would imagine then women would
naturally stare away from it
and i don't actually fully know what's
going on it may be
again a worst case scenario thing which
is you're drawn into things which are
sort of worse things
and and it had it exerts to pull over
you and that's what we might be saying
there's definitely an element of this i
think with certain women
where domination
and the strength of a partner and the
power of a partner is a turn-on
and perhaps seeing that and experiencing
it vicariously is something that they
find arousing
it maybe in some cases there's there's
some evidence that women have that some
women will describe as having rape
fantasies and
but one thing there's two things about
them obviously you know there's a
distinction between reality and and
fiction here these are not real life
desires
but also they're highly stylized the
aggressor is typically very handsome
um there's some degree of mutual
attraction to start with
and some way some to some extent as a
fantasy that both men and women have
which is being so attracted that others
lose control around you
and it may connect with notions of
playing with notions of domination and
submission
honestly of you know i could give you
like a thousand papers on a lot of i'm
saying i gave you 10 000 papers and
effective money on happiness
when it comes to questions like like
sexual desires and so on
the data is for the most part pretty
poor we just don't know that much and i
think these topics have been taboo for a
long time and i wish there was more
research into them
what is the effort paradox
ah the effort paradigm is actually um
developed by uh the term came from a
friend of mine mickey inslet who's at
university of toronto not not far from
me and the paradox goes like this
typically creatures obey the law of
least effort and this is um this shows
that this was an animal psychology world
for a long time so you know if there's
food in front of a dog and a dog's
hungry it will go to the food it won't
walk around in circles around the food
and yeah it makes sense if you're
thirsty you reach for a glass of water
you won't like move your hand and do
figure eights around and when you take
the least effort you know
you go the most direct path
and we and animals and humans avoid
effort um
so you know if there's if you're if a
dog is hungry and there's two bones and
it wants to bones equally and once close
to it and one's far away from it but go
to one close to it
common sense
the paradox is sometimes is not true
so sometimes we seek out effort
um and everyday life is full of it i
mean here's an entirely unsexy example i
do crossword puzzles i sit i sit around
on my ipad and i do crossword puzzles
and i try to spend some time trying to
figure it out i do not do it uh i'm not
gonna attract any mates with my
crossword puzzle skills because it's a
it's not really a mate attracting kind
of thing and b i'm not even that good at
it
and but i enjoy it it's kind of fun
and then you know and then and that's
such a paradox why would i
why would i
exert effort
and
and you know
deal with the opportunity costs of all
the other things i should be doing
just just to do a crossword puzzle
and you know put aside people who train
for marathons or triathlons
you know out it makes if you're doing it
because you you know you have a chance
to become a world champion well there's
like a logic that but the vast majority
don't just do it in order to to do it
it's an effort paradoxes um
why sometimes is effort attractive
as opposed to to something which one
avoids
and there's different answers um
one answer is what you were talking
about before involving the feeling of
mastery and accomplishment um another
answer connects to um the feeling of
flow
and this is um this is the work of uh
mahali sent me who sadly passed away a
couple weeks ago
and
he points out that there's a sort of
special positive feeling not exactly
pleasure but a feeling of satisfaction
to be engaged in an activity
at a level
that you're not bored
but also you're not freaking out you're
not too anxious it's right in between
um the best definition the flow i've
heard is you're in a state of flow
if um if you just forget you lose track
of time you forget to eat if you get to
pick up the kids at school you stay to
flow and there's something to flow
states which are immensely attractive to
people
though they're very hard to get so he
does these interviews and some people
say they never have in her whole life
because
it requires effort and work to get to a
flow state and it's very easy to sit on
sit on the sofa and watch netflix and
eat corn chips you know
getting some rock climbing in our
sustained musical practice or writing
poetry or even a deep discussion with a
friend
that could be tough but that's that's
what we find worthwhile
are you familiar with stephen cutler's
work
no i'm not okay so he is a researcher in
the area of flow but he comes at it from
a much more biological perspective so
what he's doing is he's trying to find
the biological prerequisites that cause
us to fall into flow and he's got a book
out that came out earlier this year
called the art of the impossible and
it's a a primer a peak performance
primer for how to get into flow it's
interesting that you said that you like
to write early in the morning because
they've done studies and they've
identified the particular type of
brainwave patterns that you have when
you're in flow and his argument is that
it is significantly easier to get
yourself into flow
if you are doing the thing that you
require to to be in flow for a short
after waking as possible because you're
nearly there i'm sure that you'll have
heard some of the stories i think it was
was it newton that used to go to sleep
with ball bearings in his hand on a
chair and then as he finally dropped off
the ball bearings would fall out of his
hand and fall on the floor and that
would be his little way to kickstart
himself into a flow state because it got
him into those brainwaves switched off
the default mode network allowed him to
see different connections that he
wouldn't have done usually but the art
of the impossible by stephen cutler is
a really good primer um for
understanding flow states from a much
more biological perspective really good
oh i'll check that out i mean i i read
flo when i was young and
man my feeling reading the book uh
reading is his first popular book
was envy and he describes these these
rock climbers who spend hours and hours
just lost in an activity or he's expert
musicians or these dancers and it's just
and you know i would love to aspire to
even close the life of flow he describes
and
the inside of a morning seems right my
my own sense is the first thing i do
when i wake up is i make myself coffee
or else i'll just fall back asleep or
have a headache but before the coffee
kicks in there's this
somewhat drowsy state
where you could just get lost in
something it's like you know
meditation for people who are crap at
meditation maybe you just find yourself
just flowing into it and then um and so
yeah that sounds great you know whatever
the more you get of that is better
another thing that i found when i wake
up because i wake up to the same uh
radio station every morning which is
classic fm in the uk and when i wake up
the news always comes on for about
two minutes and if i let myself stay
awake with the radio on with the alarm
on for longer than two minutes whatever
the song is the first song that they
choose that song is in my head i [ __ ]
you not for the next three hours it is
[ __ ] imprinted in there it's like
someone seared it into the back of my
mind and i'm so i'd love to speak i
must email stephen about it and find out
what it is about the imprinting time
that you have
first thing in the morning it is like
nothing out it's like virgin fresh snow
with a couple of footprints in it and i
can't hear anything except for whatever
that song was on a morning and that's it
i'll hear it as i walk as i'm doing my
morning walk it'll be to the rhythm of
my feet on the floor i'm like oh my god
this is like being trapped inside of my
own mind it's crazy
it's a great metaphor it's to some
extent when we wake up it is it is just
fresh
fresh snow sometimes you wake up and for
the first at least for me for the first
second two seconds i don't even know
where i am
sometimes you wake up the very morning
waking up and you may be caught in the
dream you don't even know who you are
and then the day accumulates and then it
piles up on you and um and pretty soon
by the end your
your snow that you know that a whole
elementary school is stomped all over
okay it's a new theory is the way we
need to sleep
why is suffering important for a
meaningful life then
yeah so we've been talking about about
pleasure and and that's not all so
so
here's the wrong way to think about it i
think the wrong way to think about it is
oh
i want a life of meaning
so
i want to suffer
you know i want to um i want to run a
marathon and i'm really hoping to get
blisters and to get ill and to
you know to to fail or whatever
it's not like that at all i don't think
people court suffering in that sort of
way you know you might train for
marathon you just really want to get
better and run run the marathon but at
the same time people know
that if it didn't have the possibility
of
failure and difficulty and struggle
it wouldn't be seen as meaningful
you don't want to fail but on the other
hand the chance of failure has to be
part and parcel of the thing you and i
are playing poker and and um
and if i sit down to play poker i want
to win obviously
but if i knew i was going to win if
failure was impossible i wouldn't bother
playing it's too boring
you know and there's this this insight
uh
oh it shows up all over the place uh
twilight zone episodes and zen parables
and everything up i'll tell you to send
my favorite one alan watts um
is the guy who brought in to to um
to the uk or to the united states i'm
not sure anyway british country i don't
know where he landed yeah yes yes i
don't know where he landed but but uh
but so he tells this story uh and i i
remember this because my partner and i
were watching avengers end game and it
came up at the beginning it had a
commercial for for a bank
and i'm doing whatever watching it and i
said wow they had a voice over saying
the story like what the hell so i went
home and googled it and and this the
story is imagine you fell asleep and you
found yourself in a lucid dream you
could dream whatever you want
for
75 years he said well you have so much
fun you do everything hedonistic blow
out
you wake up you live your day and then
it happens again
and he said soon later you say well this
has all been a lot of fun but it's
getting a bit boring
i want to throw some struggle some
obstacles some failure
some difficulty
in it
he goes on he talks about that he says
and if you think about it maybe that's
the life you're living now
you know you the life you would have
chosen if you could choose any life and
all the difficulties and failures and
disappointments
that's part of part of the best life and
i think instinctively we appreciate that
we appreciate that a life full of
meaning is a life full of risk and
struggle and pain
can you remember the twilight zone
story that you put in the book because
that yeah that is awesome
you get all the good ideas from the
twilight zone this um
this mobster this thug i think a killer
dies
and to his surprise he's seemingly in
heaven he's in like some gorgeous hotel
suite and everything and he has a little
angel by his side
and
and he says you know what is this well
you know welcome to afterlife wow i'm
hungry i wish there was a feast in front
of me and boom there's a piece in front
of me
he he bets on sports and he always wins
beautiful women flock to him
and he just loves it and he stops and
says
this is this is ridiculous i can't play
a game i can't i'm going insane here and
finally
he says to his guide he says you know i
want to go to the other place
that's where i belong and he says this
is the other place this is hell
and hell is where you get everything you
want
i mean it's kind of it's a little bit
twilight i think hell would involve you
know hot pokers and being burnt and
sulfur and that sounds pretty bad too
but but it's certainly not heaven
it's certainly not heaven and i i try to
remind myself you know
life
life contains a thousand disappointments
and for each one you wish i i wish this
wasn't happening you know my book number
one of the best sellers if i could snap
my fingers i would do that
but
you got to realize and as you become an
adult you realize it it can't work that
way
it's it's this great paradox you need
you need the specter of failure
and difficulty and struggle and
disappointment
you know um
and this shows up all over the place it
shows up it sounds like i'm just kind of
spouting stories but it shows up and
they did this study of two million
people uh and they asked people what to
do about their jobs and then they ask
them how meaningful is your job
and the most meaningful jobs are hard
jobs
that the most meaningful job is being a
member of clergy
working as a medical professional
of all different sources meaningful
social worker
educator
and often these jobs are low status they
are often low paying
but they're meaningful
because you're helping people you're
making a difference
because it's tough
the countries
that um that where the citizens say
they're most meaningful
i mean there's so much happiness
research saying what countries are the
happiest and answers the richest
countries the richest safest
best countries live in their happiest no
surprise at all but the countries that
have the most people say they have the
most meaning are the poorest countries
a meaningful life is positively
correlated with low gdp not high gdp
and with with you know political turmoil
and it's hard to make a living and you
don't trust people around you
and i think there's different argument
different uh theories as to what's going
on here but one thing is that struggle
and meaning are intertwined
and if i had to choose i'd rather live a
life in a sort of prosperous country
where things are going well but but um
there's some human needs that don't
necessarily get scratched uh in a
prosperous world
what was the least fulfilling job
i think it was parking lot attendant
like no one likes a parking lot
attendant
no one likes to play like you know i'm
sure there are worse jobs but it does
feel like you know it's hard to extract
meaning from it i mean i'm going to get
a little
zen here uh it's it's one of those then
things to say that any activity you know
scrubbing toilets cleaning dishes and
everything
in the hands of the right person can
have meaning there's a story that's
probably apocryphal of john president
john f kennedy turning um
uh nasa
and he stops when there's a janitor
sweeping in the corner and he says
jennifer so what do you do here
and janner says i help put men on the
moon
and you know that's there are stories of
people who do um who do who clean up in
hospitals who see their job as they
should see it as a job of dignity we're
helping sick people
and um and then i've seen people i have
had
three people close to me quit uh tenured
professor jobs
and i'm thinking
this is a job with unlimited freedom
autonomy pays pretty good you know and
you get to pursue whatever you want
and and and each of the three said i
find nothing of value here
no meaning no purpose
and so your mileage may vary
what's the relationship between meaning
and pleasure then
um
you you you can
they are separable there are people who
live lives that they say are of great
meaning
and they don't have much pleasure number
people who are who who are also describe
themselves as hedonists and say a life
of great pleasure but there's no no
meaning or purpose
but they tend to be correlated actually
it's kind of good news um
you might imagine you have to choose one
or the other but if you ask people how
happy are you and how much fun are you
having and you also ask them how
meaningful is your life how much full of
purpose is your life the answers will
tend to correlate there are people who
are kind of high in both
now there's always trade-offs
this is one of the this is one of the
things about motivational pluralism if
if if motivational pluralism was wrong
and all that mattered was hedonic
pleasure
then um then life would be simple just
seek out edounded pleasure but you have
to boundless things you have to decide
whether or not to um you know jump in
the cool swimming pool or visit your
sick aunt
or you know or practice the violin you
got these different priorities clashing
with each other
and
people differ in how they they
established a balance
there's an interesting conflict here
between dan kahneman's
insights and dan gilbert's views on
happiness can you go through that
yeah um
gilbert said gilbert is a friend of mine
and and a huge help with the book
because he thinks my book is total
nonsense he thinks motivational
pluralism is ridiculous hedonism is the
way to go and uh and he's like spent the
whole time pushing me and as he wrote
the book and you know
you you
there's no better person than dan to um
to be duking it out with as you try to
make your way through
so here's the issue and this is this is
the insights of of dan economy which is
um there's two when we say happiness or
pleasure
there's two very different things
so one thing is
what you could call experienced
experienced happiness and the typical
way to do this is you give somebody an
iphone and have it go off at random
times during the day and when it goes
off they say how happy they are
and so you have one and i have one and
500 other people have this
and then for each of us we we just we
just sum up
how happy we are from check out one to
ten maybe whenever yours goes off you're
you're an eight
whenever mine goes off i'm a four you
know on average eight on average four
you have more experienced happiness in
your life than i do
but then there's something else we could
do which is we can just ask you
how happy are you how satisfied are you
with your life where does it scan on a
scale of one to ten you know if 10 is
the perfect life and zero is life not
worth living where are you
people give you a number to that too
maybe your number is seven maybe my
number is six
these numbers correlate
so your your experience happiness and
your remembered happiness um
uh are related not surprisingly and
they're both trying son respond to the
same thing so as your income goes up
they both go up
diminishing returns but they both go up
but they're different you could be high
in one and low in another you could say
i am living the best life
but most of the time in your life you're
doing difficult unpleasant things so
you're low in that or you could say you
live just this you know this orgy of fun
all the time you're having a tremendous
time and then i sit and i ask you so so
what do you think of your life and you
say
man my life sucks you know i'm having a
lot of pleasure but i'm not adding
anything so i'm a parasite i'm a loser
you feel really sad and then you go back
to your your sex and your drugs and your
rock and roll and you're really happy
so the question is which one should we
maximize
if you choose and
conneman says
uh you should maximize
your remembered happiness your judgment
that's what people want to do people
don't just want to party and have a good
time they want to um they want to be
think they're living a worthwhile
valuable life
uh dan gilbert says you should maximize
the day-to-day stuff your day-to-day
experience you know if you spend 95 of
your time having a really good time
and then five percent of time i ask you
so how's your life and you say oh my
life is disappointing and it sucks well
on balance you're way ahead of the game
don't take too seriously your your
contemplative perspective and i'm more
on danny connell on the side but uh
because i'm not a hedonist i think i
think there's
there's a real
it
if me or somebody i loved
um
lived their life say totally blitzed out
on heroin
and suppose they could do it in such a
way had no side effects they just were
just in drooling with delight the whole
time i'd say man what a waste that's not
a good life that's a crap life
you know do you remember the example
from uh robert nozick of the experience
machine this is a great example where he
asked people
i could you know here's the deal got a
machine here
you lie down
i plug you into the machine
and you will experience this life of
extraordinary pleasure and satisfaction
for the rest of your life the rest of
your natural life you'll lie here tubes
giving you food and you'll have this
best dream ever
do you want to do that
and nozick says absolutely not it says i
don't want to
think i fell in love i want to fall in
love i don't want to think i climb mount
everest i want to climb out of it i want
to make a difference in the world
and many people including me
wouldn't go into the machine even though
we would get less pleasure
now i got to admit there's some people
who say yeah plug me in man
um i would
but i think
most of us wouldn't would you
no i wouldn't i thought about this long
and hard
one of the things that i've got in my
head so the dan gilbert uh thought
experiment he says if you are
contemplating for five percent of your
life and you are reminded of the fact
that you've lived in a swimming pool for
ages and you're going to feel bad then
you've got 95 that's good
this
seems to be a selection effect for the
sort of people typically that i
associate with hedonists the people who
are less ruminative the ones that do
less contemplation the ones that are
less introspective whereas the people
that i know who are more introspective
seem to be more concerned with meaning
now perhaps that's the outcome they've
managed to find a mode of attaining
meaning
over pleasure
because pleasure would be reflected on
more which would not give them an actual
sense of being well lived have you
considered that
if you're right and solved everybody
gets what they want the hedonist
is doesn't reflect at all and lives a
life of pleasure um that somebody
focused on meaning and purpose wouldn't
enjoy all that time in a pool anyway
because they'll be too busy thinking
about meaning and purpose so they then
they get what they want
but yeah i think that's clever i like
that but you can't make the problem go
away so here's one from danny palmer
which is one of many comments it turns
out that
you have a really fun one-week vacation
you have a really fun two-week vacation
and later on i asked you how was your
vacation how do you remember it
and you would think
if we were in some way rational and our
remembered happiness was based on the
sum of experience happiness um
you would think that um
you would remember the second the two
week one is twice as good as the first
the one week one because it's twice as
much fun
but we don't have a nice vacation man it
was good
it's what he calls duration neglect same
for bad experiences you know i've
sometimes been on a plane with you know
no wi-fi and i forgot to bring a book
and i'm uncomfortable i'm in the middle
seat and everything like that and eight
hours is twice as bad as four hours
but you're back at the hotel all you
remember was that flight sucked and it
doesn't suck twice as much
so again you have to question what to
maximize
so some people say wow that means i
should take short vacations
because i'm going to remember them the
same anyway and other people think are
you crazy who cares what you remember
it's what you experience
the interesting thing here i thought
about the remembering and the experience
itself a lot
and
i came to the perhaps incorrect
conclusion that
because the remembering self
lasts for far longer than the
experiencing self
that optimizing for the remembering self
makes sense especially when you're
younger
so there's actually an argument to be
made that you should become more hedonic
as you get toward old age
also because you run at a time to
reflect
precisely if i haven't if i have another
six months to go i shouldn't be piling
up good memories well everybody knows
this everybody knows this everyone knows
this intrinsically what would you do if
it was your last day on earth oh i'd
steal a car and i'd get an airplane and
i'd do it this thing well what is that
well it's because you're going to
sacrifice suffering and meaning in place
of pleasure so everyone in
intrinsically understands this but yeah
i think
certainly for me with my constitution
i would just optimize as much as
possible for living a life that when
remembered it it feels like a life that
was well lived um
but i wonder whether this i wonder
whether
i'm missing something there i wonder
whether no
well here's what what dan gilbert would
say you're missing which is there are
some experiences we go back
over and over and over again and we
savor them and the amount of time we
spend savoring is actually longer than
experience itself yes you know um
sometimes i don't know i've i've like
done things that you know this is so
arduous and unpleasant but i did i've
looked at them off so often in my head i
spent more time looking at them than
experiencing them and then it's even as
a hedonist everybody's happy because
it's a hedonist it's a remembered self
you're maximizing
but then there's something like the
vacation
so think of a vacation you took two
years ago
maybe think about it a few times but you
don't spend a week of your life thinking
about that vacation you took two years
some experiences are barely referred
back to
and then somebody like dan gilbert would
say it's a mistake to try to maximize
how to remember
as opposed to how they're experienced
then you get into and i'm sure you're
aware of these examples these true
freaking paradoxes so and you know this
is why they gave conor with the nobel
prize because things like this so
there's the ones involving pain
where
he actually did this with real world
colonoscopies back when they were more
painful so you take one that's
excruciatingly painful
and you stop it
and have two people get that
the other half get the same amount of
pain excruciating and painful then you
stop it
then some more mild pain
and then you ask them later the two
groups say uh which experience was worse
you know within group in some cases
between group and other ones
and what p what you find is that the
experiences which had more total pain
are remembered more positively than
experiences that had less total pain
because they ended on a
on a better note and we tend to remember
endings
it's like you know it suggests that when
you go to the dentist and it's really
freaking painful it says okay we're done
you should say
doc could you like poke me just a bit so
i'll remember it better this is crazy i
remember reading something off the back
of that it might have been written by
kahneman or someone just interpreting
his work saying one of the most
compassionate things that you can do for
that your child the first time that they
go to the dentist is to do exactly that
to ask them to extend the procedure just
a little bit to try and down regulate
the emotional trauma but what's coming
through in all of this is that we're not
rational creatures and every experience
whether it be to do with meaning
morality pain pleasure whatever all of
it is mediated by our interpretation of
it and then our interpretation of our
interpretation of it both in the moment
and after the event and this framing
response the fact that we are at the
mercy of what we thought happened and
the story that we tell ourselves about
it that's the second order challenge
that i think a lot of people have to get
past it's not just what happened to you
it's what you tell yourself about what
happened to you that's the difference
that you were talking about earlier on
between
the difference between being homeless
and going camping ostensibly isn't all
that much
but one of them you chose to do it the
other one you have to do
i agree with every word of that except
for one word
i'm not sure it's not rational
i'm not sure there's some cases where
something is irrational
if it takes you away from your goals if
it violates axioms of logic if it's
internally inconsistent
the fact that how you see something
affects how you experience it
it seems to me neither rational nor
irrational in itself it's just a way of
doing it you know and like one of my
interests is the pleasures we get from
art and and our pleasures in general and
you know
if you're looking at the face of
somebody you love they look more
attractive than if you look in the face
of a stranger even if it's the same face
the people you love grow to look more
attractive it's not just that you say
you love them more they just honestly
look more attractive to you is that
irrational
well i don't know if there was like a
rule saying that judgments of
attractiveness has to be made on bone
structure and symmetry and everything
that yeah then you messed up
but who made that rule
if i say that my kid's art looks is the
best looking art in the world
i guess that sounds kind of extreme but
if i enjoy art more if i knew it was
made by my kid than by a stranger or by
picasso than by a forger
again it seems to be neither rational
nor irrational it's just a way in which
we enjoy things we
we we focus on contrast we focus on
context
fasting feels differently camping is a
and the camping's a wonderful case
because because i hate camping and i
think you just summed up exactly why i
hate camping because i can't i can't get
the mental switch
i'm always feel like i'm i'm in a
greatly unfortunate part of my life
where i've lost my house
so it's kind of sad
talking about um wealth and the
relationship between wealth and meaning
and happiness and satisfaction
what's the true
red pill story about the relationship
between
wealth and happiness because i didn't
realize that there was another there was
another element to the after a
particular level your happiness doesn't
increase anymore story
it it's so
it used to be and and
soon enough it used to be uh
even when i taught intro psych many
years ago i used to say isn't it amazing
money is unconnected to happiness which
is what people believe and then it turns
out no that's not true more money you
have the happier you are both as
individuals and also countries richer
countries have happier people and if you
think about it it's kind of weird we
could have ever imagined it would be
otherwise money
buys you all sorts of things that buys
you in a country like the united states
it helps provides you health it buys you
and everywhere it buys you security
safety travel time with friends
freedom from exploitation
cool stuff it's just it's a lot of
things to be said for money but then the
story was uh that
it it tops out at a certain amount and i
think in the united states when the
study was done it was about 80 000 a
year and then more money doesn't help
and uh that would be like maybe 120 000
right now
and
um and then more studies started to come
in
and it's by no means clear it's true
there are studies finding that
millionaires make are happier than
people of half a million and even a
study finding that people who have over
10 million dollars or happier people
have who have between 1 and 10 million
dollars
the the difference is not huge
i mean it makes sense that money would
mat that the difference between making
20 000 and 40 000
is enormous they're never going to be
making you know
520 000 540 000 is tiny they're just
diminishing returns kind of need to do
one on on a log scale but still there's
reason to believe that the more money
you get the happier you are
all the way up as far up as we can
measure
and i think part of this is because that
money's tied to status
and status makes us happy
you know if if you know if if
you have 100 million and i have 50
million
and um
and we both know this you might be
happier you might just say man i got
more money in this guy
even though
it might be hard to think of anything
tangible you could do that i can't do
i was talking about universal basic
income with a behavioral geneticist
called catherine paige hardin and yeah
she's a big fan of paige
she's great i really really enjoyed that
conversation with her um but i
put to her
the one of the challenges around her
proposed safety net for people that they
shouldn't fall below with regards to
income because there is a minimum level
of humanness that everybody is allowed
to have my argument was and this is
something that i hadn't thought of
before because we are inherently
state-of-seeking creatures i don't think
that there is a level of ubi that will
make people satisfied
i think that you get status seeking
immediately from everybody and as soon
as you see the person that decides to
work as well as get ubi or work instead
of get ubi gets more than you
immediately until you've completely
flattened that curve
there is an argument to be made that no
one's going to be happy until we have
everybody at whatever it is number 7
billion 700
um yeah
yeah that was an interesting one
thinking about how status plays into
stateless is contrary to this sort of
utilitarian approach for money
yes and
in some way i think it's a good thing so
put aside the details of uvi because
there's a lot of debate over this is how
to do it but imagine ubi or any sort of
excellent safety net welfare system uh
the argument there is people will come
out of it um you know well fed and get
medical care and have housing they don't
have to go camping they just and and
everything is all
the basic needs are satisfied their
children are safe and that's terrific
will it make them happy
um
certainly happier than you know if
they're dying of an untreated infection
um
but happy i don't know i think a lot of
happiness is tied into um
status
and also tied into accomplishment
in ways which which cross-cut it um you
know
i would rather be um
i have a guess that somebody who won the
nobel prize in literature even if she
doesn't make that much money is is a lot
happier and satisfied than some hedge
fund manager
but you're right money itself will not
could satisfy your basic needs and it's
it's plainly a plus but it's but there's
more
and and ubi will
the problem with status by the way which
is is that it's inherently zero-sum
it gets complicated the only thing that
makes them so so if you're at the top
i'm not at the top
and somebody got to be at the bottom
the only thing that that ameliorates
that concern
which is kind of like and it's it's a
position that will wilkinson who's a
policy expert pointed out though i think
he now doesn't believe it is that
one of the good things about capitalism
is that there could be a whole lot of
status hierarchies
so you know maybe um maybe you make more
money than me
but uh my kids are better looking
maybe you know maybe you're in better
shape but but check out all the pokemon
uh cards i've collected you know and and
so in a good world any schmo
can find a place where they get at least
they do they do fair enough they get
respect
and um
and
none very little this has to do with
money and then money will satisfy the
basic needs
but but it's nice to have a world and i
don't think i'm disagreeing with paige
harden here nice to have a world where
the
the very
the very uneven distribution of gifts
that people possess is set up so that
everybody has a chance to do pretty well
in some domain or another
yeah it was an interesting conversation
i really really enjoyed i found her
fascinating because she
comes at
behavioral genetics which
the better or worse is a subject area
that has been adopted by people that are
more right-leaning and she has a quite a
left-leaning perspective about how she
wants the country to be run and so on
and so forth
one of the things that i realized was
that a lot of the problems that she was
highlighting could just be fixed by
having a better government so for
instance she brought up healthcare and
she said that healthcare should be
available to all to make it available to
all you need to have sufficient money
and ubi so that people can pay for their
healthcare i was like well we fixed that
problem in the uk and we don't have ubi
we've just nationalized healthcare so
then if you can nationalize a bunch of
other things and you end up with
everyone's got a soup kitchen that
delivers direct to their door through
some fancy
teleporting technology in 100 years time
and you can just teleport food into
everyone's houses then you go okay there
could be a point where you get to where
you don't need ubi and all of her
requirements for this minimum level of
humanness is met but you still have this
desire for status and it's inherently
going to be unfulfilling i don't think
that ubi can counter against status and
as you said as well this desire for
accomplishment and to feel like you're
actually achieving something um this is
the thing that people always bring up
that you spend all of this time on the
couch and you just think that the people
who no longer need to work they're going
to go out into the fields and start
writing poetry um i i think that there
is
i know the
the helplessness and the sense of of uh
pointlessness is potentially going to
going to come in some people find even
from a shitty job they find meaning you
know some of the ones that i've got
friends that are nurses and doctors and
they will self-describe their jobs as
shitty they'll tell me they're doing a
70-hour week and they'll hate it but
they get a huge amount of meaning from
it so yeah it's a
it's an interesting blend you you talked
about something that i thought was quite
interesting it's all the role of
sacrifice what is the the place of
sacrifice why does it play a role here
you think of in a religious context no
um
so i i have a discussion of sacrifice in
the context of religion
and in the context and again
i mean
when i talk about it i get into a topic
you and i haven't discussed yet
which is um
which is what do you do
with unchosen suffering
so right now we've been just talking
about the trade-offs people get the way
people choose in order to get pleasure
the way people choices people make in
order to get meaning and morality and
purpose
but um
but
often a lot of suffering we have in life
is unchosen and
there i'm i'm actually a lot less
optimistic i'm not one of these people
who think oh chosen and you know bad
stuff happens you get stronger you get
more resilient you do post traumatic
growth i don't deny this happen some of
the time
but um
but it it it is uh by far
not uh a regular psychological rule we
tend to be more resilient than we think
we are
but
growth
i'm skeptical about it and then you get
frameworks where we try to explain
this we try to make sense of things you
know some people think that we've
invented religion because we want to
figure out where the universe came from
where animals came from and and and
natural phenomena but i don't think we
care that much about those things
sometimes scientists scholars do but we
care deeply
about why we suffer
and why is it you and not me or me it's
not you um why did this person die and
not that person
and religion provides a framework and a
lot of religious rituals and religious
activities
are attempts to manipulate
the laws of faith
this includes sacrifice and includes a
lot of chosen suffering with the context
of religion where you're trying to sort
of take away the randomness from the
world
you want to lend a cohesive narrative
that explains why something's happened
yeah and you know so one narrative is
you know everything happens for a reason
that's not really a narrative just
saying there is a narrative and and um
i think i've done actually some research
with this uh wonderful person with
konica banerjee he's my student and
we um we asked people to remember
significant events of the last couple of
years
where um
you know good events like weddings
children being born bad events like
death of loved ones and then we asked
them
is there a narrative does that happen
for a reason it happens to send you a
message and um and what we find is
religious people
are much more likely than atheists to
say yes
but even atheists
um we'll often say yes to this we'll
often see a narrative behind it
and of course religion provides a
narrative it wasn't
random god is testing you
you are
reliving the suffering of christ
god we ignore god when he whispers but
but but he comes in loud and clear when
we suffer and it is a way of calling his
attention calling our attention to him
and so on and so forth
um
it's what to go back to dan gilbert part
of what we call a psychological immune
system
which is we're often much better than we
think we are at dealing with bad stuff
because we're very quick to tell a story
in which it actually isn't bad
but i gotta say i actually think you
know it happens for a reason is kind of
a
often a very corrosive very bad thing
to believe i think it can reassure us
but it could also lead us to be cruel to
others you know you have cancer
man happens for a reason
what do you do to deserve that or maybe
it'll make you grow good news pal you
know it's just it leads to
i think we have to acknowledge between
adults that often the best responses man
that sucks that's just
bad shitty luck i'm so sorry
um and it also leads to sort of
passivity where there's a whole lot of
suffering in the world and to say that
suffering is there for a reason it's
god's will
is a recipe for doing nothing
there's a part of me that feels a little
bit uncomfortable when
someone goes through something
and they look back on it and say that
this happened for a reason because look
at the position that i'm in now
and the reason that i don't like it when
people give those explanations is it
takes away the agency and the glory from
what they did to turn that bad situation
into the good one that they're now
in you know you you'd say that this
thing happened you got into a car
everybody everybody that got into a
really bad car wreck
three years ago and now he's in this
awesome design position at apple and
he's got all of this stuff and he's
never said that but i could imagine in a
different world somebody that said you
know look at look at where this
particular accident got me to and now
i'm in this amazing situation i'm
working for apple and i've got my
strength back and i'm running and i'm
training i'm doing this stuff
well
what's the difference between
that caused you to be in this situation
and you overcame that situation to now
have this life that you're so happy
about leading
i agree it it
that sort of narrative takes the credit
away from the person who um
you know
to think to think that i got this car
accident and that catapulted me into my
career
it strips you of
of the credit
you'd serve for the fact that that that
no you you ended up having to struggle
and having to recover
but
so that in one way it's an awful thing
for somebody to say
on the other hand if you don't say
something like that it forces you to
confront the terrible randomness of life
which is just
just freaking terrible i mean anybody
you love could be snatched away in a
second
you know anytime your phone rings it
could be the worst news in the world and
if there's no narrative that's what
we're stuck with
have you heard of compensatory control
i can guess what it is but but uh make
me not guess i saw this
a year ago so it's matthew syed he wrote
a piece in the times uh why conspiracy
theories and demagogues spread in times
of worry and uncertainty psychologists
have con con conducted experiments to
shed light on why people lose or at
least suspend rationality one experiment
asked people to imagine going to a
doctor to hear an uncertain medical
diagnosis such people were significantly
more likely to express the belief that
god was in control of their lives
another asked participants to imagine a
time of deep uncertainty when they
feared for their jobs or the health of
their children they were far more likely
to see a pattern in meaningless static
or to infer that two random events were
connected this is such a common finding
that psychologists have given it a name
compensatory control
when uncertain when randomness upon our
la intrude upon our lives we respond by
reintroducing order in some way
superstitions and conspiracy theories
speak to this need it is not enough to
accept that important events are shaped
by random forces this is why it makes
much more sense to believe that our
lives are threatened by the grand plan
of some malign scientist than the chance
mutation of a silly little microbe
yeah
that makes sense that makes sense that
rings true it and it explains you know
what would otherwise be paradoxical
which is after terrible things happen
you would imagine people abandon their
faith you know if you believe in a
loving god protecting you and then you
know you lose family the 911 or the
pandemic or whatever just kind of makes
sense to say well i'm going to lower
lower lower to priors on that belief of
a loving protective god it's exactly the
opposite
you know bad things happen and people
and people's belief strengthens and i
think it is a desire
for um for control for a narrative
and uh and more of a willingness a
propensity to see it and then sometimes
you get i think some of this is adam
golinski's work you get um you get a
sort of hoping to fiddle with things
hoping to use karma productively so in
some studies before somebody is about to
go through discover um
whether or not they have an illness or
before they go to apply for a job
they're more likely to donate to charity
kind of thinking at some level maybe not
even consciously that well this will tip
the goods you know this will uh this
will get to deity's attention and his
love will shine upon me and give me good
fortune
and that and you know you talk about we
do we push back and forth about
rationally irrational i think a lot of
that's fairly irrational
but it is a it is a powerful tendency
are there any stories from the book that
were your favorites that we haven't
touched on
oh gosh we we um
we hit a lot of them um
i think we i think we uh we hit him on
you know my i i love the the fact that
uh
over and over again
the same things converge victor frankl
and um
when we talk about victor frankl you and
i nope not yet so so we'll end with that
then um because this is um my subtitle
the search for meaning is a is a shout
out to his book man search for meaning
so he was a
a jew in austria was a psychiatrist who
um worked with suicide suicidal
adolescence
and uh when hitler came to power
he could have left but he didn't his his
elderly parents were uh were there and
they couldn't they couldn't leave
and he ended up getting swooped up and
caught in concentration camps in uh
dachau and auschwitz
and
he was always a scientist and he asked
himself the question
what distinguishes the people who
[Music]
kill themselves or give up they just
stop eating or they actively kill they
run you know they make a run for it
knowing they're going to be shot and so
on from those who are resilient and
those who hold on and he said it's not
like cheerfulness or any obvious
personality trait it's whether or not
you possess meaning
and that you have a a reason to live you
know some some sort of quote that uh
those who find a why in life can bear
with almost any how
and um
and
i feel this uh
this jibes well with a lot of the way
people are thinking about it in a way
i've sort of built my book around
the story is it viktor frankl that talks
about the stories of when they were made
to move bags of wet salt or sand from
one side of the
encampment to the other and then once
they had done they were just told to
move it back
is that from i don't remember that story
well i know that the story that i'm
pulling it from is some
jewish concentration camp in world war
ii and the point was that there was no
inherent meaning in the work yes because
once you've moved it it was moved back
and i'm not the most diy handyman person
in the world i'm waiting for whatever
switch my dad has to drop in the back of
my head but my business partner is
opening a bar in newcastle where i live
and i offered my time useless as it is
to say look i will come and
paint walls and clean up and sand things
and do whatever and as i was doing it i
don't haven't done work like this for a
long time you know two full days of
manual labor of sanding water concrete
walls to give them a nice shine or
cleaning stuff up or whatever it might
be and um upon doing that i reflected on
the work of
jewish concentration camp uh prisoners
being made to do something that is so
pointless because even at the end of the
day of this work that was pretty
mind-numbing apart from the fact i had
some good podcasts on um i was able to
look at this wall and say that's the
that's the [ __ ] that's the back wall
of this bar
and it looks it looks really
quite nice actually and i've i didn't
paint it and i didn't plaster it and i
didn't do any of the other stuff but i
had a tiny
little bit of a contribution and now
every time that i go into this bar i'll
be able to look at that wall and think i
i [ __ ] i did that for a day and a
half i did that
you helped put a man on the moon
you were like i helped open a bar yeah
exactly
yeah um
we were looking at the the the british
cover the uk cover is uh is of the book
it's so thank you it's like the fade and
it's a gorgeous gorgeous cover but the
american cover i guess i'll send you a
picture is different
and it is a picture of uh sisyphus
the famous the the famous myth
and the myth is is
the story you're telling me the
concentration camps of
someone condemned to roll a boulder up
the hill
and when it and before it gets to the
top it rolls down and you know rinse and
repeat for eternity
and you know meaning requires an end
point you don't have to make it to the
end point you know your work would be
satisfying even if the bar was shuttered
halfway through
but you have to be working towards the
end point you have to be working towards
the goal and without that
you know
work ceases to be satisfying and just
becomes
misery
if you were going to apply the sweet
spot if you were going to do applied
sweet spot are there any takeaways that
you think should inform people of how
they live or view their lives or is it
affected the way that you look at yours
at all
i'm not a
i'm not a takeaway kind of guy for this
uh it's the book is really honestly is
an exploration of why we do what we do
and less of talent my last book about
empathy was more in your face and
telling people to do stuff and i just
wanted this kind of stepping back
however
um
yeah i become more appreciative of flow
i want to read the book uh you
recommended um but of of getting flow
and i've also became more familiar with
the literature suggesting that
regardless of whether hedonism pleasure
happiness is the right goal
um seeking pleasure happiness seems to
be kind of a dead end
uh you know
there's a strong relationship between
people who think seeking happiness is
very important and people who end up
depressed and anxious and very unhappy
i think happiness and pleasure is a goal
but it's the kind of goal you get while
you're doing other things
so um so so
working on a book has made me appreciate
more the parts of my life that aren't
that much fun but are directed towards
the purpose and the goal
i love it paul bloom ladies and
gentlemen the sweet spot suffering
pleasure and the key to a good life will
be linked in the show notes below and if
people want to harass you on the
internet where should they go
uh you should probably hit me up on
twitter i'm still uh paul bloom at yale
public no longer
yeah yeah but i'd lose my blue check
mark if i change the twitter handle so
and on my web my webpage paul bloom.net
amazing thank you
thanks this has been tons of fun thank
you what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace